David Goggins posted a 48-hour challenge
which is run four miles every four hours
totaling up to 48 miles as 12 sessions
I'm doing it to harden up the mind in a
dimension that I don't usually challenge
myself it's cold outside below freezing
it's icy and wet it's windy I actually
tried to record this intro outside I had
to come back in because there's too
windy for the audio or I don't know what
I'm doing in general I don't know what
I'm doing
I didn't tried to think about this too
much just said do it I said I was gonna
do it I'm gonna do it you might be
wondering I'm wondering how long I'm
actually gonna last you're gonna have to
watch the end to find out I might swap
out a just a training session for one of
the running sessions I also decided to
do an exercise of gratitude almost like
a thought experiment I wrote down 12
things I'm grateful for one for your
session to think about when I run and to
talk about when I come back from the run
I thought this would be a nice challenge
a nice way to strip away all the literal
and metaphorical fat from the mind all
the distractions all the busyness that
fills up the day I really purely zoom in
on the things that make life worthwhile
to be thankful for them to push the mind
to its limits to see you know to see
that I still got it still a tough guy in
a way that I don't usually these days
test myself I usually test myself in the
realm of intellectual work I don't as
much that's myself in the realm of
physical work so let's see if I still
got it cold wet windy in the night still
rushing still tough let's see let's see
how long I last
watch the end to find out all right
let's go
all right four miles down 40 to go
plus the jujitsu session that was easy
but I can tell it's gonna get tough so
like I said I made a list of 12 things
that I'm grateful for one per session
the first thing I'd like to show my
gratitude for is to go all the way back
to the beginning is to my childhood to
my family in Russia and to my
grandmother who was a really big
important person in my life early in my
life and throughout my life and
throughout my memories the love the
kindness the toughness and also just the
piercing simple minimalist intelligence
that she gifted me or showed me the
importance of but of course the love
just the care and I miss her deeply I
miss the the bigger family very much so
many my formidable experiences were
there so much of the soul of my love of
literature of my love of knowledge of my
love of pushing your mind to the limit
of understanding curiosity about the
human mind so much of it was born there
whether it's in the early days of
friendship with a my close friend Yura
who who showed me the the deep value of
friendship I think I understood what it
means the Brotherhood that makes in the
companionship that with
which life becomes somehow a more
fulfilling when you get to share it with
somebody else that kind of love that
kind of friendship was revealed to me
early on is profoundly important and
fulfilling in life so and the Russian
culture at least that time least in the
context of my family we didn't have many
material possessions but that didn't
matter it was all about the relationship
about the friendships the music the soul
of the people that I that I loved and it
implanted in me again the the love the
Brotherhood the connection with other
human beings that's so profoundly
fulfilling in life alright I'll try to
talk less try to run more I have to try
to figure out the whole clothing in the
shower situation and something I didn't
anticipate with 12 sessions I guess for
most I'm gonna have to jump in the
shower and change clothes so I'm gonna
maybe have to do a little bit of laundry
okay i loving it go let's do this
alright that was 3 a.m. 8 miles down 36
miles to go and one jujitsu grappling
session that was a little bit wet a
little bit cold but we'll be alright
the the body feels good to my eye feels
good well alright this is kind of fun
like I said I'm making a list of things
I'm grateful for the second thing is of
course my family my dad my mom my
brother it's been ups and downs and
tension like all families have but
really to focus in on the most important
thing as there's been a lot of gifts
that they've given me
each my dad's really given me nothing no
I'm just kidding oh my dad's given me
the love of knowledge of physics and
science especially the rigorous of
mathematics and also the love of music
and poetry in which of revealing of
seeing the absurdity in things that
otherwise might seem painful that might
be stressful seeing the humor in all of
it that's the little bit of the jus a
little bit of the Russian in him my mom
has taught me what
means to be what means to love of course
but it also what he means to express
emotion I mean she is uh she's a vibrant
beautiful personality in human being and
I I certainly haven't heard enough of
that in terms of temper in terms of
emotion in terms of by deeply feeling
experiencing things and my brother's uh
I mean I wish I hope I inherited
something from my brother because he's
an incredible human being he's fun he's
fascinating he's brilliant he's in many
ways opposite than me in terms of how
much rich interesting personality he has
and I've always looked up to him growing
up it's always wanted to be like him I
still want to be like him so I'm really
grateful for the family I have and for
the tough times and for the beautiful
time so alright here we go let's try and
get some sleep
let's get in the shower we're almost
there only ten more sessions to go let's
do this see you at 7:00 a.m. okay that
was 12 miles down a lot more to go
feeling good it's been a while since
I've been up at 7 a.m. in the morning on
a Saturday but it feels good it feels
like I'm getting in front of the day
because nobody else is out it's just
productive I'm looking forward to uh
hopping in a shower and getting some
work done before the 11:00 a.m. on and
then the jujitsu session so some people
are asking me what I'm eating I'm didn't
plan any of this so I'm eating what I
usually eat which is meat I mostly eat
meat these days and we all make mistakes
and one of mine is to eat like I usually
do which is one larger meal I ate after
three I'm running and that turned out
not to be a good idea because I just
feel just really heavy infall which is
not a good feeling when you're running
okay so in terms of things I'm grateful
for is you know I often joke around
about being Russian and it's true the
culture the music the poetry the science
of the people is in there in my blood
and my roots and my family but I am at
this point I'm a red-blooded American
I love this country this country given
me everything I have the opportunities
the ability to do what I do the ability
to challenge myself to create things I
want to create it's an incredible
country an incredible country that
welcomes immigrants with open arms for
the most part people like me
silly silly washing kids like me with a
dream it opens its arms and puts it into
this giant pool of people that compete
against each other cooperate against
each other there's a there's a tension
there's a love and you figure out how to
how to make it all work as a big pool of
diverse kind of backgrounds you know
nobody is truly from America except
Native Americans but even and even then
there's a diversity in that history so
it's it's an incredible country in its
welcoming of immigrants and
opportunities that provides for people
with the dream and that are willing to
work hard so I'm deeply thankful for
this for this country for the United
States of America I know I often joke
around about being Russian but it's more
just the wooden humor and I am in in
terms of my roots Russian but if we look
I look in the mirror if you look at who
I truly am I'm an American I always will
be American and I love this country an
opportunities given me I'm deeply
grateful for it alright that was 16
miles for sessions eight more to go I'm
getting in a little bit of a zone
feeling good getting a lot done there's
an interesting urgency to everything
which I kind of enjoy I'm actually
getting a lot of work done even the
napping has an urgency to it I shut off
turn back on have a lot of energy the
only thing I screwed up in is eating a
little too much through you last night
but other than that feeling feeling
pretty good still would have been fast a
little bit soft but just getting out
there on the road a little cold it's a
little windy but yeah it feels good
that's good I'm glad I did it
it's a fun way to uh so wretched to the
whole thing of life to make you
appreciate everything and to be grateful
for everything so uh
what is this number four on the list of
things I'm grateful for man his
friendship in general like I said in
Russia is one at first develop really
close friendships but really when I
became slowly to say but when I became a
man was in America in good going to high
school middle school in high school here
college and meeting some really really
close friends especially in the Chicago
suburbs in Naperville a really close
friend of mine Matt you know I really
formed a close lifelong bond with him
and with other folks here with his
family and you know we don't often you
know these days we don't even often talk
that much together but there's still any
time we see each other there's it's like
we never spent a you know an hour away
so you know Matt and others have taught
me the value of friendship I'd spent so
much time working I spent so much time
pursuing my passions but behind it all
is a love for the human beings and
friendship is at the core of that of
course I also want a family and
friendship but with a you know whether
with a girl with a wife with my kids it
but I see it all just kind of part of
the same big picture and you know it all
started in middle school meeting that
weird-looking Iranian kid Matt you know
that we just kept instantly connected
different worlds different backgrounds
different histories different music
preferences the guy likes biohazard and
like Pantera heavy metal I like it's
pretty good it's pretty good but the I'm
more of a classic rock kind of kind of
guy and we together fell in love with
music playing guitar sports football
soccer tennis chess everything talking
about the biggest philosophical
questions about the universe and things
like that and it's always a pleasure to
see him and I'm deeply grateful for
having the chance to met him to met
others in naperville Allan P Jim
Jonathan I you know
Collis
countless people that have have changed
the direction of my life
affected me has shown me what friendship
is all about so I'm deeply grateful for
that then we'll forget it they're always
there always family all right let's go
do some jiu-jitsu
black belt instructor philosopher
warrior with it
[Music]
all right I think that's five sessions
now although I'm starting to loose track
a little bit
it's a fun time that's a little break
from the running and it felt remarkably
good for some reason makes me feel like
this is the calm before the storm but so
16 miles a jujitsu session just just a
few more miles to go it should be fun so
you know since I did get sore did a
little bit of nogi grappling it's a good
time to uh say that I'm grateful for all
the people that I met on the mat I
forgot who said it but it's true that
the mat is one of the only places in
this world that's deeply honest you
can't hide from the truth on the in
combat sports in general it's one-on-one
and it's just you in the opponent and
you're constantly especially in the
grappling sports where you can go 100%
and get choked and threatened of murder
over and over and over again with some
of your closest friends I mean it's an
incredible kind of experience that's
deeply humbling that I hope to be doing
for the rest of my life I see it
extremely valuable for your intellectual
curiosity and girls to be humble
throughout your no matter what you
achieve in life to be humble is I to me
is essential for happiness and for just
continuous growth but your brain can get
lazy you can start getting fool yourself
so I think jiu-jitsu for me at least
especially as my body gets softer and
you're older and don't have as much time
to Train
juju this is a great place to be humbled
where you you can train with a the young
blue belt they'll kick your kick your
butt and submit you over and over and it
kind of reminds you that you might be
good at like programming or something
like that or you might be good in the
space of science and so on but somehow
being tapped by 20 year old reminds you
one that you're mortal and two that
you're not as special as you think
you're not such a big shot and I think
that's a really powerful thing I think
that's probably an essential element of
why i know i talk about looking up to
Joe maybe a little too much but I I do
in this regard
that he is truly everything he's
accomplished in terms of both wealth and
success in comedy and so on he's still
humble I think just is a crucial part of
that it just for me so I'm really
grateful for having discovered for
having sort of come across the sport
first through judo grateful to the folks
at Philadelphia judo for revealing to me
the beauty of this art of the gentle art
of Judo and I'm really great grateful to
balance studios in Philadelphia for
teaching me Brazilian jiu-jitsu taking
me from white both to a black belt I'm
really grateful for all the people have
met in the grappling arts and Jiu Jitsu
martial arts in general I'm grateful for
my current gym Shawn Fisher John Clark
and all the people that trained there
there there's something about them
that's both deeply philosophical I think
something about jiu-jitsu attracts order
or encourages the development of
intellectual kind of chests like puzzles
solving curiosity that creates really
interesting people from all different
kinds of backgrounds and also the
toughness like like I said being tapped
kind of sharpens your mind to to
understand to understand that you're not
special and because you're not special
your approach to life has this kind of
humble curiosity which makes you a
really interesting person to talk with
to be friends with to just have a deep
conversation one to have some beers with
so I'm from Broadway jujitsu here in
Boston
- all the way back to fill with balance
studios and all the people I've gotten
to me I'm deeply grateful for that my
hope I've been for the most part injury
free my whole life in martial arts now
you know banged up here and there but
nothing broken nothing torn I hope I
really hope that stays same you know if
it doesn't so what I'll still persevere
but I do hope to be doing jiu-jitsu for
the rest of my life it's a beautiful
it's a humbling journey I'm deeply
grateful
all right I think those 20 miles but I'm
not sure I'm kind of losing track and
also not really worrying about the full
span of it but instead focusing on the
next step it's getting a little bit
tough
after doing jujitsu your body gets
banged up a little bit so you get to
feel the run a little bit but not even
just physically you get to feel the
duration of it mentally which kind of
starts wearing on you you start to this
the the sleep kind of the whole weight
of it because I've also been working
while doing this in the span in in the
ties between the runs that's the stuff
this is uh there's the ups and downs and
I've been feeling pretty good but come
down pretty pretty hard at this point
and you know I took a I took a shower
before filming this just really doing I
would say filming is probably the
hardest part having to face the camera
having the review of these parts of
myself hopefully it's a value for
somebody to be fragile in this way I
knew this was going to get tough
it might get even a lot tougher I'm
ready for it
whatever brings so far so good
physically so there's a little bit of
shin splints a little bit of ankle pain
I'm trying to make sure I keep a slow
pace um doing 9 minute miles kind of
paste to really make sure that no
injuries get aggravated I mean this
we're starting to go into a territory I
haven't been before in terms of distance
in terms of mind so let's see this is
going to be fun it's a fun test it might
be kind of silly to say but I'm really
grateful for books for having an
opportunity from an early age to explore
the the minds and the thinking and the
ideas of others through como si so I
would say most the 20th century
existential philosophers and writers
were for me early on really influential
for me at least they broke me out of the
pursuits of everyday life that were born
with the sort of the focusing the
egotistical view of life where you just
kind of focus on the task at hand and
the existential way of thought
counter-intuitively perhaps
got me to think about the bigger picture
of life got me to think about my own
mortality about the the meaning of life
of life in general so come Albert Camus
Herman has a Nietzsche of course
Friedrich Nietzsche
Dostoevsky Kafka Franz Kafka hugely
influential for me Hemingway
George Orwell Animal Farm is one of my
favorite books I don't know why just
love it for me I would spend months I
read slowly and I'll spend months in a
particular book and really take it in it
was kind of a friendship with both the
author and the ideas and that I mean
with Herman has the glass be game
Siddartha Damian Steppenwolf like all of
these books I actually I guess I could
say it dated them I was like a
girlfriend for a few months you know and
some of them I'm still seeing on the
side every once in a while and I
remember moments when there's reading me
these individual books and just coming
to a point in the book where it was like
a transformative moment I would sit back
and think about how incredible it is to
be here to be my skin to be alive and
also how terrifying it is that this
whole thing ends just mortality speaking
of which Ernest Becker denial of death
so the more modern philosophers and
thinkers a psychologist nonfiction and
fiction and just the tremendous effect
on me if I were to regret anything I
think it has to do with the my Soviet of
bringing is I never really got into
science fiction so I've really it seemed
like to my mind it seemed to me more
profound and more important to study
World War one in long war ii and the
subtle experiences of everyday life that
Camus has seen Dostoevsky described as
opposed to having to create a fantasy
world I always saw the fantasy world as
a kind of unneeded spice added to the
picture that's already fascinating
and not fairly so I felt this way
because I can see now there's a lot of
profound philosophical and dramatic work
that's done in science fiction but one
of the things one of my goals is to find
the time to read more science fiction so
if there's good recommendations
certainly the foundation series I need
to read Snow Crash dune all of these
books I need to read that that have not
been part of my childhood but really
should be part of my extended childhood
because I still haven't grown up okay
talk for way too long but it feels good
to talk maybe to escape from the writing
I look forward to the challenge of the
11:00 p.m. run or the 3:00 a.m. run and
I think will be the hardest is waking up
for the 7 a.m. and doing that run and
then a full day after that this is fun
I'm glad I'm doing it it's a good test
of mind let's go
all right 24 miles down just past the
halfway point 11 p.m. run I feeling okay
dreading going through the night a
little bit but injury-wise a little bit
of shin splints little bit of aches here
and there
hamstring from just as a little bit of
roughed up but I'm gonna be all right
it's just mental at this point which is
great it's exactly exactly what I wanted
test the mind versus the test of aches
and pains and injuries and stuff like
that
something I'm grateful for might be
ridiculous to say but because of my love
for artificial intelligence I'm grateful
for the big community the shoulders of
giants they get to stand on from the 50s
to the 60s the seventies and eighties of
the development different branches of
computer science and general mathematics
and all the things that are
interconnected in your science and
physics to on your biology to psychology
of course all those things are
interconnected in my in my work in my in
the in my view of artificial
intelligence some deeply grateful for
all those brilliant researchers just
allowing oh and of course computer
programming just believer and robotics
being able to build that stuff I mean
there's just been you know I guess it
always feels like that when when you're
at the cutting edge that you're born
just at the right time but it for me
really does feel like I've been born
just at the right time to do truly break
breakthroughs in the field of artificial
intelligence and initially when the
dream was born for me which is to
understand the mind I'm just I feel like
the kind of developments that are had
happening now the kind of tools that are
available to for breakthroughs both in
the understanding and the indigent
engineering space is just amazing I'm
really grateful that reading a little
bit now looking forward to the night
running but it is what it is got to get
it done let's go
all right I don't really feel like
recording this video but kind of do what
you gotta do I just ran a 3 a.m. run
I think that's 28 miles then I spent
maybe an hour to Dunkin Donuts drinking
coffee continue listening to an
audiobook about rocket fuel means some
sense I was a little bit delirious just
happy I'm truly happy but sort of don't
want to be talking right now I don't
want to be recording videos I just want
to jump in the shower and get some sleep
and get back to work so things I'm
thankful for may be kind of silly to say
but just my academic journey in general
has revealed a lot to me and the ups and
downs of it I'm really thankful for from
the vsms PhD that I got in computer
science Computer Engineering and
focusing on machine learning and
artificial intelligence
so getting exposure to the exciting full
space from theoretical computer science
to math physics quantum mechanics of
classical mechanics that - even
literature took a James Joyce course and
just getting going to college I love
learning and then getting an opportunity
to do research one of the best places in
the world in industry is at Google I
machine learning early especially
earlier days of deep learning
was really exciting and and of course
then to tell my tea - much less sunnier
Boston but brilliant people from all
walks of life the close knit colleagues
the friends I've developed here and more
distant from physics and mathematics -
brain and cognitive sciences and
neuroscience - the business side of
Sloan - psychology I've gotten to
experience that I've grown a lot through
that just having the opportunity to be
here and that opportunity also gave me
even the bigger gift to realize the
dreams I've had always and the dreams
that burns now of having a large scale
impact
of of working in large teams
collaboratively on one big moonshot
project it's something that's much it's
very difficult to do in the in the
academic setting and so it took me to go
to MIT to understand that that's not the
right place for me to realize a dream I
haven't so all of that is a beautiful
gift I couldn't ask it any other way I'm
really grateful for it grateful for all
the friends I had Merrill for the
connections I still have at MIT and
perhaps forever will be connected to MIT
in the broader academic community it's a
it's a real gift
that I'm thankful for okay on to the
next few miles just a few left I don't
know how many more I'm not even letting
myself think about it but I'm excited to
get it done I said I'm gonna get it done
I'm gonna get it done let's go okay I'm
gonna try to make this quick
not feeling great that was 32 miles and
it's getting rough I don't actually walk
a little bit of that the thing I'm
grateful for sounds funny to say but the
community people on the internet of
supporters in general people on patreon
people who had discussion through email
through social networks also might be
funny to say but I'm really grateful to
the people who's the the companies and
actually the people behind those
companies that sponsor the podcast I
think I didn't take on sponsors for a
while but there was a point where I
really literally needed money to offer
food and shelter so and so I thought
that monetization might not get in the
way of the deep conversation that's why
I really wanted to just do it in the
beginning the beginning and I could
connect with the company cash app and
they decided to sponsor the partners it
took you know they made it really easy
they took a risk of me I guess a guy
named Naveed especially just and there's
a bunch there's really good people
really give you but I was
kind of surprised how pleasant and
fulfilling the experience could be to
sort of tell others to use a thing that
I already use and the funny thing about
Cash Shop is because they sponsored let
me to kind of open up this floodgate I
don't know if it's because of them but
or just the general growth of the
podcast but and the floodgate of other
people who wants to sponsor the podcast
on but nothing and allows me to
completely freely choose if my hands are
totally not tired I don't have to be
sponsored by cash up at all by everybody
else expressvpn incredible thing I've
used for a long time
that's your class this place where you
can watch videos from the most brilliant
people in their field Chris Hadfield
talking about how Rockets work is just
incredible and the fact that they would
want to support the podcast is so cool
and there's like many others that could
choose from so I'm really grateful for
that support too just in general it it
allows me to survive doing something I
love which is these deep conversations
and podcast form while I work on the
main thing that is my dream the startup
that I'm working on so I'm deeply
grateful for that for the financial for
the emotional the psychological mental
the physical support all kinds of
borders people reaching out and being
kind giving me strength I a deeply
appreciated that I'm sorry if I look
like a mess these videos are really
tough to record I really don't want to
record them I am really struggling to
even finish this freaking thing not sure
I should be recording myself in this
state but hopefully it's valuable to
somebody to see the fragility for some
runners this might not be this
be just hard but not too hard but for me
um not a runner this is rough
but I said I'm going to finish I have to
finish let's go all right
I think 36 miles down 11 a.m. session
and four cups of coffee afterwards like
little little cups with a actually
cappuccino on a cappuccino machine then
I found free coffee and I couldn't stop
and I'm feeling really energetic
so body's feeling alright I'm just not
letting my mind listen to the body
there's no injury so that's really the
important thing the shin splints
hamstring from jujitsu is just you know
it's there it's there it's like like a
little reminder that I'm still alive but
it's also affecting my pace I'm I'm
saying I slid from maybe a 9-minute mile
pace to 10-minute mile pace so just
focusing on taking one step at a time
feeling alright a little bit of a
headache I think it's a salt issue that
I need to get some more sodium in
whatever they're called electrolytes
whatever so people have been asking what
I'm eating I'm eating just me same thing
I was eat feeling good overall energy
wise as this affection before people
made fun of me but you know a low carb
when I travel eat McDonald's even even
here he McDonald's just the beef patties
you know yesterday made the giant
mistake because my body my mind for some
reason wanted an oven roasted chicken
from from a grocery store six bucks
so it's cheap and it just it always
looks delicious when it's the one it's
right there so I I took it home sounds
weird to say I take a little
Thanksgiving dinner and I
I was planning to eat maybe a quarter a
half and end up eating the whole thing
so I'm regretted that and in general
I've been just feeling a little bit too
full I've been overeating which is not
good when you're running every four
miles it's interesting I think because I
only once a day or twice a day at most
this adjustment was necessary to me and
I just my body my mind is refusing to
make the adjustments I just been
overeating so for people wondering if
I'm losing weight I probably gain weight
from this whole challenge just because
I've just been eating and drinking tons
of coffee and who cares I'm not doing
this to lose weight I don't I don't care
how much I weigh I care how I feel
and in general I run because and the way
I eat is because I want to feel good and
so eating meat has made me feel really
good I don't care what I look like I
care that I feel good and it made me
feel good help me focus the mind and so
on I wanted to talk about diet a little
bit because something weird reason I'm
feeling really good right now
so you know its ups and downs that's the
amazing thing about life is if you take
just one step at a time you can feel
horrible I think 7 a.m. long I just felt
horrible and I can for this one I felt
felt pretty good so if you take one step
at a time
the the suffering will end and the good
times will come and I'm feeling good
right now next one will probably be the
hardest one 3 p.m. is because it's like
the body's right now I really just want
to rest and there's no glory in
finishing the eleventh session right
there's glory finishing the whole thing
so but it's just one step at a time one
step at a time
something I'm grateful for I've been
doing a podcast called artificial
intelligence maybe you'll listen it's
one of the things I'm grateful for is
how many people for no reason whatsoever
said yes they'll do it and they've been
really kind and generous with their time
with their mind
bringing up their mind to my style of
questioning to my attempts and growth
and learning of how to crack a hard
question how to have conversations some
of the busiest so basically my whole
strategy has been asking silly profound
questions of the busiest engineers in
the world I mean the fact that Elon Musk
twice carved out time from his day to
have a conversation with me about
artificial intelligence consciousness
the human brain and the thalamus
vehicles as as incredible and everybody
else Don Knuth just I am so deeply
grateful first people have looked up to
like Don I mean Don offered me hot dogs
after the conversation all right but
that's I could I could die happy now Don
Knuth offered me I had a long amazing
conversation welcomed me into his home
and offered me a hot dogs after to go
out for hot dogs
I mean how freaking amazing is that so
I'm so grateful from Eric Schmidt
Eric Weinstein the Sean Carroll the
physicists of the physicists
mathematicians computer scientists for
neuro scientists philosophers historians
I mean they everybody has kindly sat
down and said yes at first sat down and
just listened the way you know when you
become famous like a few of the folks
have many of the folks I've spoken with
it's so rewarding to see that that they
still truly listen to the human they you
know most of them don't know who am i
I'm just some kid sitting before them in
the fact that they would sort of listen
to me and really look into my eyes and
and like wonder what is this kid about
and really generally like human to human
be able to connect throughout the
busyness the chaos of their day that
made me so happy about the human race
that no matter where you are no matter
how small or big you are
you could still connect on a human level
so I'm really grateful for the
opportunity to learn that for the
opportunity to share that with uh with
the world and with the great media of
people through the podcast medium which
is like which i think is the one of the
exciting mediums in the future for
long-form conversation i would say it
was started with joe rogan really
brought to life that long-form two three
four our conversations there's a hunger
for them he made me realize that and the
fact that there's a platform for it
super grateful for so alright back to
running clearly I'm feeling weirdly good
it's very strange
probably going to do some work now get a
little bit get a little bit of work done
get back on the road finish this thing
refused to quit I said I'm going to do
it I'm gonna do it looking forward to uh
the last few miles let's go
alright I'm gonna keep this short I did
40 miles took a shower I did swap out
one of the sessions for jujitsu session
I decided I'm gonna stay true to the for
48 hour 48 mile challenging I'm gonna
try for uh I'm gonna try and do it I'm
gonna do eight miles a mile run at 7:00
p.m. of my body's just exhausted muscle
wise but there's no injuries period
that's it nothing else to say it's just
the mind now beautiful test really glad
I did it
it's there's a lot to think about a lot
to learn from I'll remember this
experience for a long time I'm not so
sure I'm glad I did the video I still
have to watch it maybe edit it down this
way too much talking but maybe this kind
of sharing is useful for people I'm
really grateful for the for the hardship
that my life has presented that been a
little a lot of ways in which I've been
tested throughout my life and I'm really
fortunate for that and some of them many
of them especially recently had been
self-imposed in me to choosing certain
decisions in my career to uh to really
challenge myself in every kind of way
and also test like this which are really
fun little divergences in life into a
totally different direction
I'm grateful for people that who loved
me back actually but wanted nothing more
for me but to be comfortable and to be
mediocre one of the things for some
reason there's a fire in me that refuses
to be mediocre and so when everybody
tells me even my parents or people who
love me to slow down to take it easy to
sort of relax to take what is it
somebody in the internet says uh how
bath with some soap and uh I don't know
I'm sure rubber duckies will be involved
I don't do hot baths and I don't do
mediocrity so whenever people tell me
that I hear it and it's a beautiful
thing because I feel the love and that
but I also refuse to give in to that
kind of advice
I enjoy the richness the deep beauty of
every moment so I'm grateful for that
but I'm also endlessly on satisfied with
not realizing the potential that I
believe I have so I really have a belief
a dream that I'm driving towards not
comparing myself to others
I don't care what success that if I'm
famous or my name attached to it or if
I'm successful under any kind of
dimension that this world presents
itself but I have a dream and I want to
realize that dream and that the the
opportunity to take that on to take the
full challenge of that to have the will
and the Dragon after defeat to go to the
castle princess or not who cares about
the princess it's it's about the dragon
and then maybe the princess can help me
slay the dragon too but I'm grateful for
that opportunity for that hardship and
looking forward to 7:00 p.m.
to crush that eight miles and enjoy a
nice hot cup a cup of coffee maybe a
steak let's go all right here we are
hard to believe with 40 48 miles down
zero to go some people kind of look to
the next thing right away to me I really
enjoy these moments I purposely brought
it out so it's a 10 mile route so I get
to walk now for a couple miles legs legs
are definitely shot but I feel good
mentally it's probably the hardest thing
that I've ever done physically now I'm
feeling really good now but the I would
say session seven eight and nine and now
maybe ten or is really
really rough mentally I had to kind of
suck it up and not to think about it but
if I had to take any kind of lessons
from this is if you really take one step
at a time you can accomplish you can
accomplish a lot so I really let my mind
sort of meditate on the moment really
focus on the moment taking one step at a
time and not think about the future not
planning for the future and got the job
done as silly as it is to say I'm really
grateful to be alive
really I'm dreading the whole fact that
it ends eventually but while the last
would enjoy the hell out of it and I'm
glad I did this
it's been rough at times mentally
physically but anyone gets an
opportunity to test themselves in this
kind of different kind of way I highly
recommend it big thank you to David
Goggins for challenging the world and
for letting me in on the challenge by
seeing it on Instagram wherever the heck
I saw it for everyone out there that's
actually listening to this I hope
there's some value to it keep pushing
your self to whatever your limit is
intellectually physically and most
importantly I keep putting love out
there in the world I love you all keep
grinding let's see what the next
challenge holds let's see what the next
exciting opportunity that life's brings
us
you